my name is Brett Gardner and I'm a
graduate student at UCSF and i'm here at
the Marine Mammal Center in the Marin
Headlands talking to catch you show
rates who is a staff scientist at
Berkeley and hhmi first can you tell us
a little bit about yourself and your
work at Berkeley my big round the
structural biology in biochemistry and
currently I work in the laboratory of
professor barbara meier whose lab is
interested in dosage compensation and
sex determination of C elegans and how
did you become involved in volunteering
at the mammal center when I moved to the
Bay Area from Europe back in 2001 I was
thinking of volunteering at the
nonprofit organization that involves
work with the animals so I was looking
around and came upon notice on the
Marine Mammal Center got interested
attended their orientation and decided
to join so starting from September 2002
I've been volunteering at the center can
you tell us what you do as a volunteer
I'm part of the group of the volunteers
that volunteers on the West Wednesday
night crew at the Marine Mammal Center
and we involved in the husbandry part so
that means we are taking care of the
animals while they're here at the center
can you tell us about what the mission
of the center is the mission of the
center is the rescuing and
rehabilitation of the marine mammals
center is also doing the scientific
research and as well as doing the
educational of public about the marine
mammals their health and the health of
their environment ocean can you tell us
what types of animals are represented
here marine mammal center rehabilitates
California sea lions harbor seals first
seals
sea otters dolphins and there are also
cases of whales would you want to
describe to us what you do on a shift
our shift starts with preparing of the
food for the animals and depending on
the time of the season we would are
either prepare the formulas which are
made from from Salman oil and milk
powder or or the food would be fish
typically hearing so depending on what
stage the animals are we would feed them
appropriately then we would feed the
animals at a particular time points so
that means that our feeding times are at
eight o'clock in it midnight if animals
needs requires a medication that will be
also taken care of afterwards we have to
we feed the animals we observe the
animals that everything went fine we
have to clean the pants we have to
sanitize depends make sure that depends
are clean we will have to clean all our
dishes and utensils record all the
observations and make sure that we have
forward hold the recommendation from the
vet stuff and so basically that we
repeated eight o'clock in at midnight
and we finished the crew how does the
center identify seals that need rescuing
and how do these animals come to you if
general public finds then an animal
that's alone on the beach or in the
places where it's not supposed to be
like on the street close to the humans
then people would call marine mammal
center or not if I other agency and
it'll get in touch with a marine mammal
center who would then send volunteers to
collect the animal and bring it bring it
to the center there are also cases where
animals are entangled in the nets or in
some kind of marine DEP deep divers and
they would be on also rescued in the
water so there are different ways how
the animals are found can you tell us
how you train these pups to fend for
themselves in the while we are trying to
minimize
contact with the animals as much as
possible so that animals don't get
dependent on humans so that means we
would not talk while in presence of of
the animal we would handle the animal as
quickly as possible during the feeding
time we would stay away from the fence
and we would try to avoid that the
animals associate food with the humans
so that means in the case of the
California sea lions we try not to for
example have hand have a fish in a hand
and showing it to the seal because
California sea lions extremely smart
animals and they can make that
connection so we're trying to keep them
as wild as possible during the time
they're at the center how long are they
usually at the center harbor seals
depending on on their condition whether
they're sick whether have infection or
whether they're just being separated
from their mothers they can stay at the
center and depending on their progress
how well they they gained weight and
they learn to to feed they can stay at
the center between two to three months
where do you release them the release of
the animals happens at the other remote
beaches where there is not much of a
human traffic and usually they're
released in a group of two to three
animals depending on how many animals
are ready to be released at that given
time do they each get names each of them
gets a name they're named by the rescue
volunteer group and they are very
creative with their names and each of
the animals has their own personalities
as well
so it's very easy some animals to be
recognized every weekly to come back see
see them and recognize them how many
animals are usually here at one time on
average years we would have up to 35
animals inside but there were a couple
of years where we had almost 70 animals
do you see any parallels between working
in lab and working with the harbor seals
let me rephrase we do warm so with
bacteria it doesn't matter right you
know yeah you repeat the experiment bad
but I mean bad but it's no big deal
right here if when you put a tube into
the animal you really want to make sure
that you're in the right spot and that
you're not harming the animal because it
would be devastating to have to lose an
animal due to a mistake human mistake so
when you have a long day in lab this is
completely different afterwards oh yeah
yeah do you think it helps to have
something that's separate yes it puts
everything into perspective and get you
out of the lab
something out and let me to meet new
people from different walks of life and
we have been now most of our crew cheers
together so we we worked well as a team
so you get to learn how to work with
other people do different backgrounds
what's your favorite part of
volunteering depending on the time of
the season there are different things
being out outdoors because this is a
really beautiful spot to the word the
Marine Mammal Center is located working
with the animals and having seen them
progress and eventually be released it
is really very rewarding
you